it's become something of a tradition for
the Forum to sponsor a kind of prequel
to The futures of entertainment
conference that will begin tomorrow and
run over the weekend and we're
especially pleased to do that this year
because the topic has such suggestive
importance it seems to me uh concerning
not only the question of the diffusion
of media around around the globe but in
particular the way in which uh West
Africa perhaps Africa more broadly if
our panelists are able to address that
in a lesser way uh is coping with and
gobbling up and using exploiting uh
the the Cornucopia of technological U
possibilities that seems to have opened
not all of them maybe I'm putting it in
too too generous a way and we'll leave
it to our panelists to tell us whether
whether whether there's a dark side to
these matters as well my job is mainly
to introduce our distinguished moderator
and he will do the rest of the work for
us I should mention again for those of
you I also want to uh say say a special
word of thanks to the CMS students who
have already endured wearily a long
tedious lecture and here they are again
I won't forget this we're happy to see
you and I expect wonderful questions
from you in the question period um we uh
the format of the Forum is widely known
but briefly let me outline it for the
for those of you who are not familiar
with our basic function basic operations
uh the first in the first hour there's a
or 50 minutes or so there's a sort of
conversation amongst the moderator and
the panelists and in the second hour
almost always the highlight of each
Forum the audience gets to uh it say
there are microphones on each side and
we ask you to come up and speak into the
microphone identifying yourself if you
prefer we' like you to do so uh uh you
can ask questions or even make brief
comments and that interaction with our
audiences is often as I said the
highlight of our events I hope as you're
listening to our speakers you'll be
gathering your wits for very sharp and
uh and serious questions our moderator
tonight I'm very we're very fortunate to
have here is Ralph Simon uh the founder
of mobium of The mobileum Advisory Group
which studies innovation in mobile usage
in such countries as Nigeria Kenya
Uganda and South Africa
he served as an executive at Capital
Records blue note records and Emi music
and he co-founded the zoma group with
Clive Calder of South Africa he's been
called the father of the ringtone
because he is said to have created the
first ringtone company in 1997 but this
doesn't these these descript these
descriptors don't capture the extent to
which Ralph Simon has been uh a Pioneer
a leader in the in the uh uh uh one of
the the earliest people to recognize the
profound implications of mobile
technologies especially for uh uh third
world and underdeveloped areas and we're
very fortunate I think to have him here
Ralph where are you there you
are thank you very much and uh very warm
welcome to you this evening on this cold
night here in Boston it's lovely to be
here I just got in from Mumbai traveled
uh from Mumbai uh I left at 4:00
yesterday afternoon Boston time got here
at 4:00 this afternoon but so excited to
be here and to see such a distinguished
audience of uh people wanting to learn
about not just West Africa but also
about the incredible way in which um
cultural products such as film
television music is changing the way
that people interact in Africa and
what's adding to all of this to give you
some kind of setup in the way that all
of this works is the immense explosion
of the mobile phone as an instrument by
which people not only communicate with
each other but are getting uh their
their content and entertainment in a way
that no one would have imagined so let
me give you some statistics just to give
you a sense of this they're now about
800 million mobile phone users in Africa
it's expected to grow Beyond 1 billion
over the course of the next 5 years and
this is significant because right now on
a global basis there are just under 7
billion mobile phone subscribers or
users on a worldwide basis uh uh with uh
the device now becoming increasingly
much much more of the touchscreen
smartphone variety what's interesting
about this is that in Africa the
smartphone such as the Apple iPhone has
got a negligible usage in Africa because
it's very expensive and the dominant
phone used in Africa is the feature
phone basic entrylevel phone but you're
seeing an enormous growth in the
touchscreen smartphone because of the
development of uh very lowcost
smartphones that are not only internet
connected but also can tilt in a
horizontal frame to get very very good
resolution for film content and
television
content um where's my sheet I think
you speakers I took his not away very he
likes a challenge it's okay it was
actually a test thank you very much
could improvise no I should have had
that on my phone but never had it um
we've got a really distinguished Trio of
uh participants speakers authorities
here this evening that I think will
really add a lot of muscle to what we're
going to be talking about and the
objective tonight is to do three things
we want to first of all give you a sense
of the latest developments in terms of
what's emerging in entertainment in West
Africa with the implications of what
that's going to do for the rest of
Africa secondly we want to take some
kind of view on what's happening with
African music and how African music and
African creative products are spreading
not only in Africa but also in the
diaspora and the diasporan African
communities particularly from West
Africa are quite substantial on a
worldwide basis and thirdly we want to
have a look at some of the new trends
that are going to be influencing um
things in West Africa that are touching
the lives of people both in Africa and
also internationally and how there's
this very very interesting kind of
cross-pollination where we seeing for
example African cont content that has
got contextually colloquial relevance
having relevance in cities in the United
States like Houston or uh even in
Michigan where there are large clusters
of the diaspora uh for example uh in the
Bronx the Bronx has a huge cluster of
garans you can be walking down a street
in the South Bronx and hear people
conversing in gah anybody here speak
G
anybody here speak
Tre
three anyone here speak Yuba ebo or haa
one anybody here that speaks
kza no one speak Koza anyone speak
Zulu anyone speak
Shona yeah very very good okay so I'd
like to take this opportunity of
introducing our very very distinguished
group of speakers is who'll be
conversing with us and giving us some of
their wisdom and Pearls of knowledge
that will absolutely help supplement
your awareness and understanding of this
really exciting area and what makes it
so exciting is we're seeing a real
Revolution going on in the emerging
countries the developing markets uh in
the same way as we saw some really
fascinating changes in the results of
the election here over the last couple
of days where the political landscape
has been changed forever seeing the way
that uh things uh really manifested uh
with the Obama victory in a similar kind
of way we're starting to see the PO the
cross-pollination of cultural impact
starting to affect communities in the
developed countries but coming from the
emerging
countries so first of all I'd like to
introduce uh you to our uh group uh like
to introduce you first of all to Colin
mlay Colin very very good looking bloke
there uh col is the managing director of
the burkman center for internet and
Society at the Harvard Law School and as
co-founder of Harvard's International
Technologies Group and at burkeman uh
Collin's research pairs Hands-On
multi-stakeholder collaborations with
the generation of data that reveals
Trends challenges and opportunities for
the integration of communications
Technologies in developing communities
Colin welcome give him a big hand later
gentlemen he's a HomeTown
boy of course we uh always have uh
beauty and brains and of course that
applies to all the men as well as the
women on this panel but it gives me very
great pleasure to uh introduce you to
fzi Manda fzi uh and her family were
originally from Zimbabwe that's why she
speaks Shauna and she is the business
development manager in the New York
office of the very very important
Nigerian company called ER Roo Partners
who are really uh crusading in a very
interesting way uh in the in television
and film and specifically looking at
driving Nollywood uh around the world
and she leads the development and
execution of the US advertising and
sales strategies for ioko so please give
fzy a very very warm
welcome and last but by very no means
least we have a some would say a
superstar with us well he is a superstar
not only in his own right but he's a
superstar in his country of origin which
of course is Gana Derek uh ashang leads
the the the band suage so soulage I beg
a pardon a group that produces an
Eclectic blend of Hip Hop and reggae
Funk worldbeat West African High Life
how many of you know the rhythm of West
African High Life fabulous just small
number well if you just imagine Calypso
with soul
Calypso with an African kind of feel
Calypso with secret source that soon as
you hear it your feet start moving
that's Derek's kind of stocking trade
and uh he's also known as DNA that's his
kind of stage name is subri which is the
name of his blog and uh he recently
hosted the Oprah radio's Derek ashang
experience and also has been very
involved in constructing a uh a really
uh some would say revelation TV series
on Al jazer the Arab the Qatar network
called The Stream so please give a warm
welcome to Derek
Derek Dereck you're looking very uh very
hip tonight I see you've got nice uh is
that something from Ghana that you're
wearing around your neck these are my
cowe shells a lot of artists in the
United States you know everywhere talks
about their bling and their diamonds and
things and we know that there's been
some uh political turmoil on the
continent for people to have all those
diamonds uh so cowry shells were
actually used as currency back in the
day around West Africa and so this is
what you could call my traditional bling
it represents wealth and power and
nobody got shot for me to have it so you
certainly are not shell shocked at this
point because this is exactly what you
need to do to show who's who in the zoo
yes indeed very good okay so at this
point just before we get into the mix we
thought we'd give you an interesting bit
of Sizzle and we'd like to get fuzzy to
come on to the podium here and show you
a real so that you can get the context
of what Nollywood is we're going to show
you some little Snippets so why why
don't you come up here and it's over to
you and let's uh give people a a nice
little orderve before we get into the
meat um so this is Sizzle wheel showing
the content that we have on aoko
Partners uh which is a great
representation of the type of content we
have in
Hollywood
[Music]
[Applause]
shut welcome home Dr
Gra
[Music]
ni
um there you go that's a a glimpse of
Nollywood and oroko TV so come back and
join us here because U what we'll do now
is go through some particular issues
that we think will have relevance to
your understanding of how this important
art form as well as the cultural art
forms of West Africa are starting to
expand and just to give you some context
the Nigerian movie business Nollywood is
worth about $250 million a year in terms
of its uh uh earnings capability about
uh between uh a th000 and 2,000
different kinds of movies are made each
year so to give you some context 250
movies or so are made in Hollywood 800
or so in Bollywood different Bollywood
languages tolywood Bollywood sandalwood
and then of course in Nigeria you have
between 1 and 2,000 but generally around
uh 800 movies of a kind of feature uh
substance um and this has been an
industry that's been going since
1960 so if we think that the Nollywood
business has been going for some 60
years it's only really in the last 10 or
15 years with the arrival of digital
technology editing and shooting and
cheaper uh the democratization of the
production process that we are seeing
this huge explosion of creativity that
in turn is influencing stuff now Colin
you were recently in Nigeria tell us
about some of the things that you saw
and give us a sense of when you were
exploring this medium what was some of
the Impressions that you came away with
as a Nollywood
virgin can you believe that he just got
off a plane from Mumbai this is I don't
I don't trust this is remarkable um so I
I have to disabuse you guys of a few
misconceptions that Ralph may have um
conveyed one I'm not an expert uh two
I'm not like these other people as you
can see I don't have that that deep
nolllywood experience I actually started
going to Nigeria probably about four
years ago uh on another topic altogether
working on technology and Civil Society
with um Pal's here um Ethan Zuckerman
and Mike best and we knew a bit about
Nollywood um and we just we said we're
in Nigeria how can we not explore this
phenomenon which is as you got a sense a
totally remarkable phenomenon where you
have an indigenous film industry that I
mean yeah maybe it's been around since
1960 but generally talked about since
about 19 uh early 90s late 80s so it's
20 years of this kind of thing that's um
basically producing one to 2,000 films a
year that is in the top three of you
know production it's in the top three
250 to maybe 500 million I've seen SE up
to a billion dollar Revenue estimations
so one of the things that you'll hear
are that we don't really have good
numbers it's big that's what we can say
it's really big the second biggest
employer in Lego state so this is a
state you know it's a city of 20 million
people a state of 40 I don't know
however many million people massive
source of employment um a million or so
jobs directly or indirectly in Nigeria
so it is a uh a huge economic uh Force
but also a huge cultural Force right and
this is about this is Nigerians telling
Nigerian stories uh to other folks in
Nigeria but because of um in part uh
substantially actually because of the
unlicensed copying the piracy uh
expanding that market from the initial
communities in Nigeria where the films
might have been targeted to uh elsewhere
in in uh in the country to Ghana across
the border down to South Africa to
Liberia to the entire continent and then
uh much further a field reaching
diaspora communities but as I think um
fzy will tell us reaching communities
all over the world and building an
audience like that of the tel noas where
you have this very kind of um culturally
based um storytelling that is about
Nigeria and you even parts subp parts of
Nigeria right um that is all of a sudden
resonant uh with a much much broader
community and is done um very much in
spite of any kind of institutional
supports you know there's no copyright
there's no Studio system there are no
studios uh there's no money these things
cost 25 to $50,000 to produce maybe 10
days to shoot a month or you know a
month and a half or two months for the
the whole movie to turn around they can
of course go up to probably a million
dollars but by the by buying large
they're low-end they're not all as fancy
as the as the sizzle reel we saw many of
them don't have great sound quality
don't have great lighting have jumpy
Cuts they're filmed on cheap cameras but
uh they're storytelling and people love
them and they love them everywhere and
so it's just this totally
um it is a remarkable phenomenon where
um culture economics um uh storytelling
Community all these things converge uh
in a way that I think none of us could
have predicted or engineered um and uh
we're right now at this very exciting
moment that says what next and what's
going to happen so fzy one of the things
that we've noticed about Nollywood is it
tends to be principally around themes
dealing with moral dilemmas that face
modern
Africans tell us a little bit about what
ioko is and does you've got a library of
some 5,000 movies so tell us about some
of the movies that you've got and
secondly we'd like to know a little bit
more about this diasporan audience
that's outside of West Africa because
you seeing a lot of what you doing and
the development of of uh of getting the
movies to this diaspora give us some
sense of the extent of it yes so oroko
partners are basically trying to
revolutionize the way that nolllywood
content is distributed so kind of the
world that Colin explained we're really
trying to move it to the next level so
because Nollywood has always been very
DVD driven it's always been a physical
Market it's been very much restricted to
the local market so if you're abroad you
didn't really have access to this
content uh whereas so the CEO Jason joku
really saw a huge opportunity here where
you have this massive diaspora this huge
demand where people can have access so
by bringing the content online uh We've
really been able to to um aggregate the
diaspora where everyone has access to
this content and we've really seen
massive growth uh we're now in 180
countries just showing that there is
demand 180 countries 178 countries um so
hold on a second if you look at Nigeria
as the font for this which is
principally the West African movie
business comes from Nigeria garan movie
industry is not as welldeveloped
if it's 180 countries where is the bulk
of the Nigerian or the African diaspora
what what give us some numers on this
some demographics on it sure so for our
traffic the US actually is our largest
market so we have about 25% of the users
are here and it's pretty much In Pockets
where you'd expect to find African so um
in the DMV so DC Maryland Virginia uh
New York uh we find a lot in Atlanta um
a lot of those hubs um and another 20%
in the UK because as you can imagine the
proximity to Africa the're lot there uh
there also countries that we were
surprised about so our other top five
markets are Canada Germany Italy
Malaysia
hold on a second Italy and Malaysia why
would those have a passion for Nollywood
well you'd be surprised you have a lot
of these like a small pockets of
Africans where you're not as surrounded
by the people than your community so
this is a way to connect with home this
is a way to see um you know some of the
values that's why you're saying um in
terms of the content the things that are
really popular it's a lot of these uh
stories from home you've got romance you
saw from the scorel um you know the also
the morality side you kind of like
seeing the good guy win in the end the
girl get the boy so really these stories
where you can connect with home and I
think that's why there's a lot of this
popularity where people canect don't a
lot of the films also promote Christian
and Islamic values exactly strong
religious thread that runs through a lot
of them yes there is a strong religious
thread um why is that um actually a lot
of funding also comes from the churches
I mean you said there's not a lot of
money pouring into it but you do see a
bit of funding coming from that end so I
think that's the reason why you can see
a lot of these moral uh themes in the
films so of the 5,000 movies that you've
got which would you say would be the two
or three big titles and why are they big
titles uh well interesting so we've had
uh Blackberry babes and Facebook babes
are two of is that is that Blackberry
babes that doesn't sound
very you'd be surprised uh it's actually
uh been um very good uh sequence there
been one two and three actually um and
so you get a lot of BlackBerry phone
babes um yeah so you find a lot of these
stories uh have to do with uh you know
technology nowadays so even though it's
about romance and these stories a lot of
it has to do with people being you know
cool with your blackberry everyone's
very techsavvy now whether it's on
Facebook um so it's very interesting
merging of um technology and modern
themes into these stories really
reflecting how um Africa is today you're
not necessarily always going to see some
of those um more you know traditional
portrayals that people would expect from
seeing in Africa you know you're really
seeing very modern stories where
technology is very relevant and you're
seeing that a lot in the content and in
terms of uh the way that uh it's it's
developing its own TV appeal as well
is there now a TV channel that is
catering for this kind of material here
in the United States so that's an area
that we're actually looking to move into
you know we realize this is a multi-
channel world so we should be on every
device where our users are so we have
the mobile aspect but we are looking
into uh potentially going to TV starting
with in the US and UK uh we're still in
the beginning stages of this we have a
bisb team in New York doing the research
because it's a very massive undertaking
uh but we think it is important as an
African multimedia company to also being
broadcast and how do you go about
communicating with the producers of all
of this material do you have
relationships with the producer
community in Nigeria and you effectively
pay them an advanced amount uh as people
traditionally do in the movie business
to secure the rights outside of Nigeria
to those pictures yes so that's
something that distinguishes oroko is
that we have relationships with each and
every one of these producers so when
Jason joku the CEO went out to found the
company he actually out to you know the
Alaba Market you know where all the
producers are and met with each one of
them directly because we wanted to make
sure that they were compensated fairly
for their content because you know as
you know piracy is a huge issue and so
what we've done is we want these
producers to have an incentive to
continue to produce this content
increase the quality of it so we signed
and negotiated deals with each one of
them directly uh you know we have
licensing between 5,000 to 15,000 to
have exclusive rights to the film
dollars dollars yes um so we do give
them that's pretty low um um you think
it's low5 to
$15,000 relatively speaking well this is
for the digital rights I mean they also
get the the DVD
stream digital yes so what we exactly so
we've brought in an additional Revenue
stream from these producers where you
know before it was only DVDs very small
amount theaters but we' brought in this
other massive uh stream of Revenue uh
since on the digital side it can be
monetized through advertising which is
very lucrative and can I ask a question
on this sure and and is there Revenue
sharing or is it just straight up here's
your five grand and then you sign the
rights away and whatever you guys can
make on it is um it's just licensing uh
but we're going into starting going to
co-production agreements as well so that
we're also content owners along uh with
the producers but also I think
interesting context is the the cost of
these films because an Hollywood film
May cost $50,000 to produce so if you
license it uh for 5 to 15 you're looking
at a minimum of 10% of your budget gain
back from the digital rights which pre
previously didn't that was a revenue
source that didn't exist at
all exactly so this is really changing
and I'd like to question of the audience
while we're on the subject how many of
you here in the audience are
screenagers
nobody none of you are screen
agers okay let me pose the question in a
different way how many of you look at TV
and your iPad and your mobile phone at
the same time
okay so now how many of you are
screenagers thank you much much better
so Derek this is a good segue in for
this I this whole phenomenon of people
becoming screenagers this is not this is
a universal phenomenon in Africa I mean
you're a very successful musician
guitarist bass player keyboardist you uh
uh were working last year with uh the
founder of the UR
rhythmics um da Stewart Dave Stewart in
Hollywood uh in not Nollywood but in
Hollywood and uh you were apprenticed at
the Berkeley School of Music where you
uh really got your chops uh really up
and you also did something special for
channel o yes and give us a sense of
what you've been doing because youve
focused on the musical side which is as
important absolutely so I um you know
came up here to Cambridge got an
expensive education up the street at
Harvard and decided that the best thing
I could do with my parents money was to
learn to play
guitar they loved
that so um once I escaped from the
medical school track I decided I wanted
to find ways to communicate important
things to people and being a person who
grew up in many different countries born
in Africa in Ghana raised in Brooklyn
and in Saudi Arabia and in Qatar I
always felt that Artistry was a way in
which you could bridge the gap between
societies and so I formed a band and and
one of the things we did early on is we
created a music video for a remake of a
classic West African song called sweet
mother and one of the trends that you
find is that in on the continent a lot
of young people aspire to like the
lifestyle and the imagery and Aesthetics
that are coming from the West at the
same time there's this Dynamic of
wanting to assert one's own identity and
and and to have one's own voice be
shared and I would say that in recent
years that Dynamic has grown as
technology has enabled us to better
connect to one another and to better
share our own perspective so Nollywood
is for example very much you know
Nigerian voices telling Nigerian stories
to Nigerian audiences and now the people
are looking in and being like Oh that's
kind of interesting um so what we did is
we did this remake and we did an Old
West African song called sweet mother
which is like the most popular song in
the history of of African music arguably
and um we basically did it with a whole
new perspective and that song had
explosive success in Ghana the video
charter number four New Perspective did
you we hip hoopify it um and without
without taking away the Ganan um
actually this is a good I'll show you
I'll show you can you pointing to
someone in Jonathan who's that so this
is Jonathan he's in my band and we were
he he's give him a hand make him feel
good if you grab that microphone so I'll
give you an idea of what I'm talking
about specifically um so sweet mother
has anyone here heard this song okay Co
there a big that's not bad we got some
crew so the basics of it says
sweet forget you the way you suffer way
you suffer for
me sweet
mother
sweet and everyone loves that we all
grew up hearing that so what we said was
simply one two for the cool and you we
rock a three four when you hop for more
I give you five and six for that lyrical
mix y de flip these scripts with
an pra for great for mommy his Mercy
look to bommy treasure more say know the
truth is
keep child to grow wise he must learn to
listen so ear then no man's Army no
riches no Pi take love my m away sweet
mother forget you the way you suffer
where you suffer for
me sweet
mother
W
[Music]
sweet
[Applause]
right son cross through a diaspora
transatlantic baby no but that is really
that is fantastic because what you've
done is you've showed something that
someone like Professor Henry Jenkins had
spoken about at length over the years is
contextual colloquial relevance exactly
you're taking a hip-hop mode welding it
into something that's really your own
and creating a whole new sound with it
exactly and this is a phenomenon that
you find across the continent I remember
when I was in in college in the '90s
going home and and learning about you
know all my research doing all this
stuff I did a lot of very important
research on cultural relevance and you
know practices of of of of cultural
expression primarily in the clubs of
arra cuz that's where the kids practice
that's what we express kof there you go
that's right that's one of them for sure
and but the thing that was interesting
is you go there and you hear all the
same songs back then it was the 90s it
was Jay-Z it was Missy Elliott and the
whole nine then you come into like the
2000s and you go back and all of a
sudden the music you hear you still hear
the the American Artist but 80 90% the
music is in the Indigenous languages and
that was the birth of what's called hip
life it's hip-hop and high life what
languages would those have been so that
would be in in Chi primarily in got a
number of things some people also do it
in housea sometimes you'll get some
stuff in ever but Chi would be the
dominant one and also in what we call
pigeon which is what sweet mother we
just sang in it's like hybrid slanged
English West Africa can you give us a
translation when you were when you got
into the pigeon give us a sentence in
Pigeon and then tell us in kind of
americane so okay well the the song that
that I just Sayang we like sweet mother
so sweet mother I know go forget you
right that's we get that I know right
and then it's like if you went into like
the verse it say when I know chop my
mother no go chop if I don't eat my
mother won't eat when if I know sleep my
mother no go sleep if I don't sleep my
mother won't sleep and in our version we
also started it out with G so if I
say it means slowly do it
slowly
and basically that means my mother told
me don't dance in the
kitchen because if you fall
down I will beat your ears until you
learn how to hear
right but every time I fell down my
mother didn't beat me she held me and
she said don't cry not n Nana is my Ghan
name right now look at me grown man I
rock a c to still never met a woman as
Stellar as she African queen that's who
Miss OHA be OHA means Queen in tree and
thank praise J for all the greatness
that form and when you talk about this
localization basically we do that song
in English pigeon pwa and tree they're
very few people on the planet that can
understand the whole thing but they get
the sentiment and they get this idea
that you're reaching out to them so the
the point of that is to illustrate that
what's happening on the continent is
people are rather than consuming simply
what's coming from the outside world
they're starting to articulate their
unique distinctive identities and those
are hybrid identities African identities
are by their very nature you know I grew
up in a household where everybody speaks
four languages so that you can
communicate with your neighbors I talk
to you and yours I talk to you yours
talk to you and yours just to be polite
that's normal in arra right so I think
when we talking about what's going on at
the intersection of culture
and Technology we have an opportunity
for people to truly articulate Global
identities to a global community of
fellow participants fellow um um lovers
of art and culture as equals and that is
something that is not existed for the
continent and it's got profound
implications not only culturally but
politically and economically this is
absolutely correct this is a very very
important area and if you're studying
this area or trying to understand the
waves of the future that are going to
influence this area here's an
interesting piece of technology that's
been developed in New York just over the
last few months because a lot of people
in Africa want to be gloal does anyone
know what gloal is I see you nodding
your heads not gloal warming there's
some gloal warming but gloal globally
local so let me give you an example in
an American sense Lady Gaga has got
Global phenomen she's a Global
phenomenon but she's not yet
gloal Derek is taking his Global
sensibility and making his work gloal so
this what this technology does very
interesting it's a technology that takes
the phoni from someone's voice so Derek
would have that song that you just did
with Jonathan right yep and what we
would do is take the phoni from his
voice we would then go to to a Lyricist
let's say we wanted Zulu we go to
someone in South Africa to record
against the production track that Derek
recorded on we would then get a Zulu
lyric and a Zulu playback singer to sing
that song we'd then take Derek's voice
from a sample from his spoken voice and
just wrap the
phoni around the Zulu playback singer
and the net net result of what we get is
Derek singing in Zulu his voice or H the
tomra of his voice but with the
playbacks phrasing of the Zulu he won't
even have to go into the studio to do
the Zulu so this is something it's great
cuz my Zulu
sucks but think of the implications
because one of the big problems in
Africa has always been that it was very
hard for someone from the south to
migrate their cultural style East or
West so for example one of the best
proponents and someone who is always
considered to be the Bob Marley of
Africa was a Zulu singer by the name of
Lucky dubet unfortunately he died he was
uh killed in a in a hijacking that went
wrong but lucky dubet was the first
Southern African artist to actually go
and play Stadium performances in Uganda
Nigeria he was huge he had a reggae feel
but everything that he did was either in
English or in Zulu he dreamed of being
able to be a an African performer so
Derek if you had the opportunity to have
gloal vocal on your vocals such that you
could have a following in Swahili yes
and in southern Africa and in chucha in
Malawi is that something that would
appeal to you it would be massive and
it's one of the biggest things facing
one of the biggest challenges facing for
example Ganan musicians is that the
Ganan Market is only but so big and you
know 20 million people 20 million people
in Ghana 20 million people outside of
Ghana hold on a second 20 million
outside yes why did they all
leave well now we go talk politics oh
yeah I mean that right there um they
left the same reason you know I I left
because my dad came to study in the west
but I I couldn't go home because there
had been a first Rawlings coup then a
second Rawlings coup and not to put it
all on him a lot of people have done CS
in Ghana but they were really
disappearing people and um so a lot of
people and particularly a lot of
musicians in the 80s left I mean you
literally would talk I remember um
talking to mat matono of oisa the late M
tono OA of oisa which is huge band I
mean Ganan band that used to tour with
the Rolling Stones and these guys are
amazing but he was talking about how
there's a whole generation of Ganan
youth who didn't get the mentorship of
established musicians because all the
established musicians fled the then
dictatorial regime now we're very happy
that we've got democracy now things are
better but what it means is that you
you've got so many gs in got got all
these Gan outside of Ghana if you're a
Ganan musician you only really have that
domestic Market cuz it's hard to reach
all the people out in the diaspora well
what if you could just connect even to
the other Continental markets and that
becomes difficult because you may be
singing in your own language and they
can't connect to it you know there's a
saying in Ghana that you your English is
as good as you can afford right so if
you're not highly educated you don't
have money then you may not have the
ability to sing in a language that's
more universally uh heard and it might
not even sound as good for what you do
so that kind of technology means that
before you even got to go and track down
all the people who might like you in
London and in the Bronx and in New
Zealand Etc that you could be looking at
Lagos and Nairobi and Cala and darar and
Johannesburg and there's I mean to
literally create these domestic
exchanges of culture I think would be
profound economically for the artist but
it would be a real powerful weaving
together of a continental fabric so
let's take one of the Great West African
artists probably the number one or
number two artist in Nigeria is a rapper
by the name of Twoface mhm so if Twoface
we've been trying to get Twoface hooked
up with little Wayne in New
Orleans and then trying to get Little
Wayne's voice to sing in
Yuba because if we can find some
cross-pollination there's no reason why
we should not be meshing together West
Africa yes and West Los Angeles or West
Africa and Louisiana and people are
that's exactly what they're trying to do
for example we did a a track a couple
years ago with a guy named Reggie
rockstone very well know he's really
like the Godfather of hip life he's the
guy who founded the hip-hop movement in
Ghana and right after we did the thing
with him he showed me a video they were
about to release where Reggie rockstone
from Ghana and two-faced edia from
Nigeria and beanie man from Jamaica all
got together and they did a track
together because they all realize that
there's this massive uh sort of
diasporic audience and the Jamaicans
have been the best at this a tiny tiny
island with an incredible Global impact
I there's no country other than the
United States and perhaps the United
Kingdom that could argue that they've
got that degree of cultural impact
around the world musically and if you
take it per capita Jamaica beats
everybody right so those three got
together and they're like we can Market
this in Ghana in England in Nigeria and
in Jamaica and the but it's still hard
hard but they're thinking that way the
degree to which technology can start to
facilitate that I think you see an
explosion of creativity because the
artists already want it Colin You' made
uh when you some of the observations
you've made when you were in Lagos one
of the things that uh has been very very
important good luck Jonathan the
president of Nigeria elected in the
recent election um decided that
Nollywood and Nigerian cultural content
soft power as has been evidenced by what
India does with Bollywood
or in fact what Hollywood does for the
United States tell us about something of
the Innovation Council because you you
heard about that and it it intrigued you
well I mean I think uh it's absolutely
there's a huge opportunity there and
you're starting to see politicians uh
and leaders in Nigeria recognize it
right so if most most people probably
not those inside this room uh they're
primarily familiar with Nigeria because
they get a lot of emails from Nigeria um
which it turns out is not the Nigeria
it's not really the best foot forward
and a lot of them aren't actually from
Nigeria they're from Ghana but that's
all it's easy to play blame the
Nigerians someone's always blaming
someone but um but whereas this is uh
you know with recognizing that there's
happy stories and sad stories this is a
totally different kind of opportunity
right to to to tell the story to tell
your story how many people are employed
by the movie business in Nigeria this is
what I said so they estimate again uh a
million people directly and indirectly
so it's a it's a big industry it's a lot
of people um and uh a lot of money um
but uh there there's a real there's a
money problem there there's a there's a
huge Finance problem um and piracy which
has created the market also exacerbates
a lot of pressure exacerbates a lot of
the the issues which is to say You have
about two weeks or so to make your money
back from your film aside from whatever
roko TV uh gives you for the online
version um to make your money back for
the film before it enters into kind of a
piracy market and you're basically
competing onetoone with the Pirates so
that means that there's not a huge
incentive um to uh to invest in films to
really do high-end films because it's
going to be pretty challenging to recoup
your um your investment and you know the
fact is is that something like 99% of
all the revenues are from DVDs and vcds
so they're a dollar or $2 a pop there
are about you know a dozen theaters in
the country uh and they primarily don't
show Nigerian films they will for the
opening but that's really about it so um
there's a really big challenge with on
one hand you have sort of piracy eating
away at these revenue streams and you
don't have alternative revenue streams
that are beyond the the little the
physical object uh that people uh there
buy um so there's a real challenge to
figure out how do you crack this nut of
injecting more money uh into the
industry so that you can do better films
you can take longer than two weeks to
produce them uh that you can uh get
better skill sets in there um and that
you can change some of the the sort of
less productive dynamics of the Nigerian
film industry so um to your point so
they the government has done a couple a
couple different government officials
have done done things recently so one is
with um world Bank support good luck
Jonathan announced a $200 million fund
uh for Nigerian films that's not chopped
liver that's a big amount of money it is
but they haven't given any of the money
out so it's Cho what do you have to do
to get the money so well this is the
question nobody knows what you have to
do to get the money except for one film
so you can't just write a script and say
this is going to work there been you
know there have been a handful of
apparently not so great applications and
one jointly uh joint Nigerian American
production that has gotten the money but
it's their funding it appears they are
funding kind of more of a Hollywood
model like a even going back to to a
35mm film and thinking that it's going
to be a much higher uh production value
you know a million dollars a million and
a half dollars for film so that's one
model right um there's not really the
theaters there to support it it's not
clear how that's going to work and to to
for my taste most importantly that is
not really in sync with
the what is Nollywood right there is a
cultural you those films may or may not
appeal to the rest of us but to a lot of
people around the world they appeal
tremendously right and so you have this
$200 billion fund which is kind of
pushing in one way kind of pushing but
it's a carrot that apparently no one
wants to eat or that there you know that
things work such that who knows what's
going to happen so I would say that uh
as of yet has not been a success we are
um not holding our breath but crossing
our fingers and anything we can do to
help them to kind of see their way uh
clear to making that work uh will be
great but there is a more promising one
that we're also involved in uh which is
the state um the state Innovation
Council recently formed body in the
state of Lagos uh where it's employing
so many people uh Governor realizes and
this Innovation Council realized that
there's a real need to do um to kind of
upskill the industry and so arguably um
Nollywood is sort of plateaued is no
longer on the medior rise that it was
although perhaps at the roko TV changing
things a little bit there's absolutely
an appetite to say hey what do we need
to do differently and one of those
things that people agree on is training
that we got to get better at what we do
so increase those production values um
do different kinds of film there's a lot
of sort of uh interest and doing and
retaining the spirit of Nollywood that
has been so successful but expanding it
and doing kind of a Nollywood 2.0 um
more of the same not in the way the
other fund is set up so this my my
friend and um colleague Amy Corgan who
unfortunately couldn't be here tonight
um along with Bond maruay and a team of
other folks who uh some of which did the
the documentary this is Nollywood is's a
fabulous documentary if you haven't seen
it um are starting this nolllywood up
program right now as as a matter of fact
where they're training hundreds of um
Nigerian filmmakers in script writing
and uh film in all aspects also includes
citizen journalists that are learning
how to I don't I'm not sure you know
there's an application process um and
they're kind of just starting it now
it's a multi-year project um and we're
going to kind of figure out what happens
I mean my role is relatively small we
have a team of fabulous students at the
burkman Cyber Law Clinic uh uh um um who
have been doing amazing research on
alternative uh Revenue generation
different kinds of Licensing what can we
learn around the world from how you
bring in money especially when you have
some of the challenges that you have in
Nigeria so looking at everything from uh
tip jars which actually have an
interesting residence in iera to a
Kickstarter model to all kinds of
different ways to say hey what do we do
um to make this industry work and not
just fight back against piracy which is
a challenging thing to fight back
against in a in in a direct fashion for
a whole bunch of reasons we can discuss
but how do we create value how do we
create other revenue streams so these
artists can get paid so they can
continue to do do movies and do even
better movies so there's a lot of
exciting things happening really just
beginning right now so if you got a
million people working in in the
Nigerian Nollywood industry the creative
Industries are now becoming a Trope that
is being used to a greater degree and
effect by some enlightened African
politicians and in fact if you look at
the British model where 2 million people
out of 60 million people are employed in
the creative
Industries in the last uh Chinese 12
5-year plan that was elicited about 9
months ago the creative industries were
brought in as one of the major vertical
so there's recognition on a global basis
about the importance of creative product
creative Industries creative culture
that can be exported transported and at
the same time transport people into new
ways of thinking Derek what do you say
about that well I think that the it's
interesting I had a conversation um with
a A Friend by the name of Cynthia
Schneider and I know another friend
Chris is here he knows what I'm I'm
going to say Cynthia Schneider uh Chris
and I Chris Shields actually another
very accomplished person in the music
space uh has put on festivals across the
planet and some of the the highest end
ones now uh Chris cynth and I were all
part of something that the Brookings
institution put together for the US
Islamic World forum and they actually
brought together a group of people in
entertainment to look at how
entertainment can be a force for um you
know basically Bridging the Gap between
people and her M uh Cynthia was the
former US ambassador to the Netherlands
under the Clinton Administration
typically you're not going to see a lot
of State Department people fighting hard
and talking about the power of the Arts
but I'll give you an example that's
non-african just to put this in context
there's a show has anyone here heard of
Afghan
Idol a couple of people okay Afghan Idol
is is basically the um the Afghan
version of American Idol pop Idol
exactly but it's not licensed they
created their own thing version of it
that's in their and people come and
singing indigenous music and the
indigenous languages it's highly
localized and basically this thing has
become arguably the most successful
program television program in Afghan
history if you look at the recent pres
parliamentary and and the presidential
elections in Afghanistan you actually
had more people voting in the finale of
Afghan Idol than voting in their
parliamentary and presidential elections
now you want to talk about nation
building right and everyone's going to
talk about economics and National
Security and good governance Etc but the
reality is the most profoundly
successful democratic practice that the
country has experienced has been through
the form of this television show and the
irony is you know the people who could
perform people vote for folks from
different ethnic groups everyone talks
about Afghanistan so tribal they vote
for each other women are a part of it
young people all kinds of different
folks and so there's an example where
you see entertainment being put into
context and it having a powerful impact
on broader issues in society and I think
that this is something that leaders need
to take more seriously I personally this
may be my bias but I think that in
governmental circles and and oftentimes
in business circles people don't take
the art seriously enough right and so
what winds up happening is you get a
bunch of people together who maybe they
not good at Art itself so they don't
want to think that it's that important
and most of the people spend their lives
getting really really good at it don't
learn as much about you know garnering
votes or or or writing business plans or
whatever the case may be so Artistry is
um marginalized but all of you when you
get a chance go home tonight turn on
your television when you're in the car
or or walking home to listen to the
radio see how many commercials you hear
with no
music just count them what percentage of
the commercials when you go home and
watch the news tonight will have no
music and you'll start to see what I'm
talking about it's ubiquitous it's
everywhere it is a profound level of
human
communication that we all engage in but
we don't take seriously and to the
degree to which governments leaders in
the private and public sector can start
to look at music as a resource as a
human resource human capital I think
that you actually find ways of finding
greater solutions to your problems and
rather than sending all the Marines out
there in Afghanistan to blow things up
to teach them about democracy maybe you
make some better TV shows and you start
getting the same effect I'm not saying
just drop we'll drop videos of I Love
Lucy you know I Lucy I think that I Love
Lucy could go a long way but but
seriously it's not to say that you don't
want to look at the traditional
mechanisms of development but it is to
say that you have got this profound
cultural Arsenal that is always
overlooked uh because maybe the people
who make those decisions don't have a
full grasp of the power and what they're
dealing with so f when looking at the
things that you're doing how much does
social media come into your thinking
about promoting these various titles and
developing this diasporan audience how
many how many Facebook followers for
example can you track so social media is
a large P of roko and actually we have
um a Facebook API Incorporated in it so
everyone can comment on movies and so
there's a very social element to it and
you actually see people getting really
into it you know all the movies saying I
can't leave we did that I can't leave we
did this um social is definitely a huge
uh part of it and talk about what you
were saying I think um on the global
gloal is that the term you used um and
being able to disseminate information
you know socially uh I think we do a lot
of that with I rocking which is our
music platform so we also have um a mus
music streaming site uh which has um so
what have you got You' got IR rocken
which is the music side yes and IO TV
film side exactly um and on IR rocking
what we have is we have about 400
artists with 35,000 songs and we've
created the ability for which language
uh mainly uh I think with English but
also some languages in Nigeria so y
sorry I'm saying I'm butchering them but
um across the Spectrum and um so we've
created a way for people to download the
songs and be able to share them and we
get thousands of downloads and it's also
globally so like you said if someone
over here you don't necessarily have an
African radio channel there's now a
mechanism both through thy rocking
website and also through our apps where
you can download these songs create
playlists and easily share them with
people so I think that's another way
this form of Technology that's
facilitating this interaction being able
to share the African culture that we
have C can I just pick up on one I mean
this theme here so I think I mean these
observations about um sort of human
nature and the power of Art and music
and film are you know so readily
apparent to any of us who go and watch a
movie or listen to a song or see you
know some art or make art or or whatever
it is or play games right these are
there there's like some very basic um
human kinds of things that we do um and
it's remarkable how much sort of the
policy world the development all the
world that I'm kind of very familiar
with just disregards this stuff and says
oh no no that's not valuable that's not
real that's not serious um but in fact
it's serious in terms of job job
creation
self-expression uh Crossing cultural
boundaries I mean we're talking about
lots of countries Nigeria included which
have serious cultural divisions and
these are all the things that
potentially transcend those barriers
doesn't mean they always do or our
Panacea but that there's a lot of power
there and I think um something that we
can and governments and and makers and
and consumers can all do together is
lean into that and figure out how do
these things allow us to connect in ways
that we for whatever our reasons are uh
are unable to do otherwise so there's
there's a lot of power there to unleash
and we're not there yet so Colin let me
give you a hypothetical would something
like the Gates
Foundation if you went to the Gates
Foundation and said you could have an
influence with your cash in this
cultural sphere have you come across any
examples by The Gates Foundation for
example in this well as it happens uh we
are actually in discussions with that
very Foundation um and uh uh and some
others but in particular um talking I
mean aware of this tremendous power and
the reach right this is a community of
folks that you cannot otherwise reach
they're uh across the country in the
case of Nigeria and around the world um
and you can reach them for for this very
low price of inserting some ideas into a
film you know some tens of thousands of
dollars um so they're eager um to
explore the um kind of inclusion of uh
social themes like health issues into
dramatic pictures so not what they call
an NGO film not like okay here's the
thing we're going to teach you a lesson
and everyone's going to run you know
screaming because it's terrible but it's
art and it's dealing with the most
profound things that we deal with which
are like loss and risk and fear and all
the things we do or dealing with old and
new right it fits right into um all of
the kind of the classic uh Nollywood
things where you have you know sort of
new ideas oh should they get this
medicine versus old or men versus women
or whatever the you know the the
particular tensions are but with other
socially relevant issues and this is the
way that we play out you know so much of
if you look at our film here in the
United States at least some of it um not
all shoot them ups but you see that
there and so to include um some of those
themes and this is a a group uh at USC
called Hollywood health and Society has
been working on this we're working with
them has been doing this for many years
kind of advising filmmakers to get the
facts right on health issues but also
helping script writers to think about
what are creative and Powerful ways to
include those really human themes into
their films so I think there it's a it's
a IT addresses the funding issue it um
gives new storylines which is exciting
it has potentially fabulous you know
powerful Health outcomes um and also for
me it's there's another interesting
aspect particular around the health
stuff is you want to reach people right
so if you want to make them aware of um
services or other ways that you know
they could kind of pursue the ideas that
they learned about in the film uh you
have all these mobile phones it's kind
of the same as what you as a just a
regular old filmmaker want to do you
want to know how to reach your fans too
so what we learn in that space and what
you learn uh reaching your fans through
mobile phones are absolutely um I think
uh uh kind of reinforcing and can can
inform us how better to use this new
ability to reach our audiences to engage
them in the substance of the film or in
the way you were describing uh in sort
of the community aspects of film which
when we don't have theaters we lose so
many of those Community aspects which
are so kind of culturally enriching but
also for health or for other you know
who of you here in the audience has
heard of a visioner from Africa by the
name of alpes
Patel okay so I'll tell you a little bit
about this man when he was six years old
he and his family were kicked out of
Uganda by Idi Amin moved to the UK he
decided that when he was a young man in
his early 20s he'd moved back to Africa
he went to Kenya and he became intrigued
by a company in India called Micromax a
company that built a lowcost touchscreen
smartphone and he said what I'd like to
do is to be the first one in Africa to
bring very low
touchscreen smartphones to Africa he
started a company called my phone m
i-f n e anyone heard of my phone well
you can get an iPhone like my phone or a
my phone like iPhone for about
$35 internet great pictures and alpes
Patel over the next two years is
envisaging that he's going to sell 50
million of these phones he bases himself
in Dubai macius and Nairobi and he has
got a huge relationship now with ety
salot which is the kind of big
Challenger to the number one Telco
operator in Nigeria which is South
African company MTN MTN have 53% of the
market in Nigeria but ety salot are
using my phone devices and getting
movies and tele ision and music to the
populations so Derek if people had
access to change their very basic
feature phones phones that couldn't give
you the internet couldn't give you uh a
video what do you think people are going
to do if they can get a phone for 20 to
$30 I think that it's going to be
explosive uh for a couple of reasons one
uh smartphones are not simply about
communication right smartphones about
changing the way in which which we
consume content and interface with the
world so it literally opens up their
world I remember I was doing some stuff
some years ago with an organization
called taking it Global and taking it
Global is is written taking it Global
it's it's the everyone calls it TIG it's
out of Canada started by two really
young brilliant like change agents and
they they started when they were like 19
or 20 and it became This Global
phenomenon and if you go on TIG you
would find at the time that the largest
population or the largest number of
people for any country were from uh the
US which is funny because it's Canadian
I think the second largest number were
probably
Canadian the third largest number
country that had the largest number of
people there was
Ghana there's so many people in Africa
that want to be wired and this is like
seven years ago or or more so many
people wired but if you want to get
online in Ghana you've got to go to an
internet cafe you know easier to find an
internet cafe in our than in Manhattan
or in Boston frankly because here we all
have our own laptops our own computers
but there that's not the case when you
start taking this device and you're
going from the feature phone which you
all will forget that's the kind that you
use just to make phone calls and text
basic Nokia from 10 years ago exactly to
the smartphone where now you have a
wireless connection all of a sudden you
have this whole world that's open to you
now take it a step further I know a guy
by the name of Marvin Hall uh in Jamaica
who's done this incredible project in
collaboration with some people at MIT
and at Stanford and Harvard and he's
basically created this program to teach
robotics in Jamaica and he teaches
robotics to kids in the worst ghettos of
Kingston the year when I first started
collaborating with them uh Jamaica had
the highest murder rate on the planet
higher than Iraq Afghanistan whatever
right and he's going to the communities
where all that shooting is going on and
teaching kids who everyone else has
presumes are illiterate
Robotics and one of the things that he
told me is he's like you know what like
it's amazing like yeah we can get all
this information we can show them all
this stuff but you know what's the key
what's going to take it to the next
level is when they can get all the
information all that access and they can
program these robots all from their
mobile device and that's when you start
having lowcost smartphones available so
I think that that is the next big
revolution Africa completely skipped the
landline thing you know my grandma had a
cell phone before I did people and Ghana
were sending text messages before us
knew what SMS stood for and it is
expensive to do this in Africa because
text messaging still is quite pricey for
local community exactly and you're
basically paying for minutes and so you
can send your text and use your phone
until you pay for minutes but once
you've got a model where you've got
affordable phones and you've got the
providers migrating to data packages
that are they actually fit the domestic
Market it's not just like you're talking
about people being able to read their
email or check Facebook you're literally
saying that this is going to be your
computer cuz you don't have another one
and I think we'll be shocked at the
degree of innovation that Africans will
Pioneer once they have greater access
this is absolutely correct and in fact
it's it's a tremendous change agent all
around because you're finding now that
with these with internet connectivity
over the last three or four years
they've been gradually laying the
submarine cables down the east and west
coasts of Africa and here's an
interesting factoid for you when the
connection was made into Kenya there was
a spike of usage of music videos because
For the First Time with the internet
cable being connected people could get
YouTube videos on their mobile phones
this is something that is also growing
very fast we see the big success of
Gangnam Style how many of you know about
Gangnam Style see everybody knows about
it now interesting nearly 700 million
views on YouTube only 5% of those views
are in Korea 95% the rest of the world
Derek we've got to create the African
equivalent the Nigerian equivalent of
Fufu style there we are Jonathan here we
are it's coined here tonight anyone here
blogging what did you say it was Fufu
style how do you spell that fuf you and
I don't mean it like
that
that's okay um so here's an interesting
question for
you uh how many of you here in the
audience know a woman by the name of
chimamanda enoi
adichi 1 2 3 4 5
6 okay let me phrase the question
differently how many of you here know of
a novel first came out in
2006 called half of a yellow
son a fantastic book it's really well
worth a read and the reason I mentioned
this to you it's a drama that brings
together the lives of four people during
the struggle to establish an independent
republic uh in
Nigeria and this movie the movie of the
book has just been completed in Nigeria
it's very important for Nigeria because
the movie is directed by be bandel and
it features Tandy Newton who won an
Oscar and CH chiel edor well-known actor
but here's an interesting thing they
started shooting the movie and making
the movie before they had a commitment
to get money a young woman who is a
merchant Banker in Lagos but loves the
creative Industries was desperately
trying to raise money for the movie she
could not raise it she went to the heads
of the major Industrial conglomerates in
Nigeria
and they all said to her you're making a
movie that's not business can't you
rather do something where you can build
a factory that produces food stuffs she
said don't you understand this is food
for the mind if we make a movie about
this great novel this is something that
would be beneficial she eventually
raised $3 million it's just been
completed they're now looking to try and
get this movie uh distributed overseas
but the interesting thing about it is
it's also the one of of the first times
where great a great uh writer has taken
their work to the screen and is turning
this into something so fzy tell us about
are you seeing this in terms of some of
the movies you're getting with ioko that
are looking more serious than blue uh
blueberry girls Blackberry girls and and
movies of that nature yeah so they're
starting the new phenomenon I guess
called new Nollywood where they're
trying to do more of these big budget
films putting more behind just you know
$30,000 in funding and it's actually
part of the reason why we launched um
aoko TV plus which is a subscription
platform that we launched in July where
users uh you actually have to pay $5 a
month where you can watch the content
with no advertising and there was a
reason for doing this because now with
this more High budget content in order
to get the digital rights to be able to
recoup it we need users to start paying
so I think we're definitely going to
start seeing this trend where we're
seeing more um substantial stories
really serious stories want to show the
world about Nigeria and in order to get
that funding um you know you definitely
need compan companies like us trying to
put in the rights Colin you know they
say that the internet Society texting
tweeting and all that stuff is leading
to people being much more shallow in
fact a successful book came out about a
year ago called shallow and how the
internet is changing people's writing
are you seeing uh the development of uh
creative writing on your trips and your
work that you do in in
Africa uh no but that's because because
I'm not looking uh for it but I don't
buy that argument uh at all why not I
think it I mean I think I don't think I
think that's just a polemical argument
that um people throw out there to say
that you know it's like it's not like
the good old days um so I I I don't
think that's I don't I don't want to
talk about
it what I would much rather talk about
is the the this really interesting
development right so this is this film
will probably be released on the sort of
Oscar schedule like this could be a real
International Film right so this is at
once really exciting like you mean you
heard the story that's to me that's an
amazing story right this is a woman who
has no business doing this and she makes
it her business to do it and she does it
as a dream right so that's like the
that's like a Hollywood Story or an
Hollywood story as the case may be there
should be a movie about that um but but
for me it raises a bunch of questions so
one question is is that going to be is
that film going to be resonant in
Nigeria and outside is well attending
Newton his box office so it could well
be it could well be or it could be too
highbrow right so they've done some
other highbrow films that have flopped
in Nigeria so I so for me a question is
and I think a question within the new
Nollywood is are we making um films for
the global for the for the for the
global diaspora and for the rest of the
world are we making films for Nigeria um
because it's in some sense it might be
changing the the capacity to
commercialize and to get revenues for
those films internationally might you
know that's a bigger Market in some
sense or at least for now until the
internet arrives in a more kind of
robust fashion so so I think that that's
an open question what direction are
these filmmakers going to go and do they
have to choose or is the um are those
markets actually going to converge and
maybe they're not so different after all
what do you say about that I think the
the two factors that and actually I'll
be interested to hear what y'all y'all
think as well because I see a bunch of
very intent faces but there there are
two things that I think are worth
considering there one is the degree to
which African communities celebrate and
lionize the success of their own folks
outside I mean like even for for me
things that I've done out
here when I I think of the first time
like I got interviewed by Oprah Winfrey
for this thing and and and the amount of
phone calls Facebook messages tweets
whatever from Ghana alone just from
people because everybody knew about it
because it was such a big deal the how
did they get to know about it online
it the word spreads like wildfire right
and and then they or I mean I would
literally be doing my show and then
people would be checking in and TW and
tweeting in or sending in a note from
all around the world and including from
my home country um someone like Chu who
I actually know because we did a a film
together years ago um is a star like
someone that Nigerians at home and in
the diaspora are very very proud of uh
Idris Elba you know if you talk to gan
half Gan they will let you know Kenyans
and Barack Obama this it only takes half
we'll take a quarter whatever it is you
know and and I think that so what winds
up happening so that that's one
phenomenon we love those of us who are
able to succeed in a broader case like I
literally will have people tweet me and
be like oh my God he's one of the only
uh Ganan that's verified on Twitter
right and like they keep track whenever
somebody new gets verified that's one
thing the second thing is you know I
remember when my my uncle my youngest
uncle or my mother's youngest brother
used to run like a little movie facility
out of my grandma's house he took the
garage over he put up a big screen and
got a projector and they would play
movies in there and I remember cuz I
would sneak in and I watch American
Werewolf in London when I'm like eight
years old and I was dying of fear and
then I was like oh my God it's terrible
and my mom's like you can't watch that
but the point is everyone wanted to see
all those Hollywood films and there
wasn't and there still isn't the kind of
distribution for theatrical release so
if you combine these two phenomena where
on the one hand we want to see ourselves
represented on a on the global stage and
on the other hand we're looking at the
stuff that's already on the global stage
and and we love Sylvester Stallone since
way back in the day or whatever the case
may be and you start looking at the
possibility that we could be telling our
own stories on that Global stage if you
deal with that distribution question and
the questions of how do you monetize it
or both uh around the world and
domestically I think there's actually a
big audience for higher production value
product the problem is if you make that
higher production value product right
now and you don't have an audience for
it outside the country there's no way to
make your money back within the country
and this is the challenge facing this do
we yet have a West African Bruce
Lee that's a good
question um not not to my knowledge
because action movies obviously are
movies are are huge but but I'll tell
you like you know I watched this um this
uh series have you all seen this uh in
British series Luther with ID Alba
anyone seen it I mean that thing is so
cool and I know so many Ganan and and
other people cuz idrus is not thought of
as African he's thought of as like he's
an English dude but we think of him as
African because every English person is
either African or Caribbean and them
Caribbeans is African too I'm just
saying you know that that's basically a
lot of black people in Britain will tell
you other stuff but you ask them you
won't get past the grandmommy from
Tobago right so basically the the the
the reality is someone like that is
really starting to be that image like
he's that action type of guy but he's a
clever detective and this and this and
that and the whole world was watching
and they're just like yo this is amazing
I think there's a lot more room for a
lot more of that Daniel Craig watch out
let's get some questions from yourself
here on the floor uh would you go up to
the microphone tell us your name and
then pose the question to our Holy
Trinity
here thanks uh my name is fola carrian
and I work in London um and I was really
interested in this idea of soft power
through film and so on and I was at a
conference on Nollywood a few years ago
in London and I asked some of the
filmmakers how they thought about the
fact because it was very much about how
do we bring the stories out to other
audiences and I asked about um this idea
of talking to ourselves and talking to
others so Nollywood the films are
fantastic because they have lots of uh
stories that are recognized in different
areas of Nigeria that are folk stories
and moral kind of tales of what happens
and what that means morally but when you
take them out of context people don't
understand them so the village girl goes
to the city and is attacked or whatever
we we can take that very literally
outside but we know that this represent
some idea about uh Pro progress and
modernity and so on when we're from that
culture I mean I'm not not but I
understand them because I'm interested
in it um and so how is this going to be
dealt with in terms of telling people
about Nigeria making films that speak
out and at the same time continuing to
use films that help us figure out who we
are internally as people so that's
something that affects all film
Industries but I'm wondering is there a
lot of thought being given to that or
how would that be kind of coped
with what do you say so so I I would say
I I met some really amazing Nigerian
filmmakers in Hollywood we were talking
about this earlier and these are
basically guys they're not Nollywood
filmmakers these are guys that are
working you know making a TV products
for Fox and NBC and and making indie
films and produce music videos for you
know major record labels etc etc etc and
are starting to make feature products
and basically what they're doing is
trying to find ways that they can tell
their own stories with their own vision
and a context that can reach a broader
audience but that still has relevance at
home and I think the the thing to
remember is that you know and especially
like I'm a Ganan but I'm going tell you
about I'm the only West African in
this in this panel so I'm going try you
know but basically you know Nigeria is
one of the most
literarily impactful countries on the
planet I mean the the literature that
has come out of that country the writers
that have come out of that country are
absolutely
mindblowing and part of the reason I
think this has happened is because of
the success of some few people but also
because there is a tradition you know we
speak of like the oral tradition and
people think oh oral tradition means
pre-literate Society but it's it's goes
much much further than that right I
could sit here and I could tell you a
story about something I care about or I
story about something that I care about
right in in my language literally it's
tonal right so it's how do I if you ask
me do I know F and I say in means I know
her if I say in it means I don't know
her in our culture it's not just what
you say it's literally how you say it so
you've got this literary tradition
that's all about how you say things and
saying them with power and with love and
what we're looking at now is the
opportunity to translate that from the
page and onto the screen whether it's a
Silver Screen or it's a mobile one and
what I would argue is that there are
more economic factors than anything that
are preventing that from happening and
as you start to deal with those economic
factors the issues of distribution and
making your money back monetization
drawing in Greater investment but being
able to get a adequate return on that
investment that you're going to start
seeing more and more people tell their
stories in ways that have that cultural
specificity but that are still
applicable to a global audience anybody
who's has anyone lived in La all right
only a few people who who here has seen
swingers right more people swingers was
a huge success crazy Indie flick if
you'd never been to La you're still
going to love it but if you've been you
get all the subtext and I would argue
that you're talking about cultures where
they already have a tradition of
speaking profoundly to that subtext but
in a way that can reach out to broader
audiences and we're just looking to
bring it to a new medium so will this
lead us to having like a YouTube kind of
civilization or will it lead to more
serious film making I think it'll be
both you know and I think that you're
going to see more serious filmmakers
start taking things like YouTube more
seriously let's go for another question
there's a good-looking gentleman over
there take a mic tell us your
name hi Ralph uh good to see you again
we met couple weeks ago in Ghana at the
aln conference so oh we did yeah we did
that's
right I cry all the
way so my name is Victor malet
uh I'm Alum of MIT and I'm a Founder
co-founder of real african.com which you
may or may not have heard of yet we're
actually fantastic company a fantastic
company tell them what you do thanks
Ralph um we are basically a very little
brother of uh ioko in a way we're a
video on demand platform for African and
Caribbean content uh we launched about a
year ago and part of what we launched uh
for is the idea of how do you present
African content content globally um and
not just also Nigerian content but South
African content Kenyan content
Zimbabwean content all that needs a
place where it can live and where people
can find it so that was the idea that is
the idea behind real african.com um so I
really found what you've been saying
very interesting uh I think Derek you
have a really great point about the
content that is let's say produced in
Ghana can have so many ways of touching
people in Mal or Zimbabwe elsewhere and
and making those connections is a great
way to to Foster some cultural exchange
that is not really ever existed do you
dub do you dub your pictures into the
different languages no we do not dub any
films yet um we focus on english-
speaking content right now and when it's
in local languages we have subtitles for
English a lot of our audience right now
is also the diaspora so it's the US
diaspora uh we have some great
Partnerships with snag films and with
hulu.com so so that's how we operate um
and I'd be really interested in hearing
from fzy about how ioko thinks about
Distributing to the rest of Africa
because that's really the you know 800
million1 billion Market it's not just
the folks in you know sitting in London
or in Brixton or whatever it's really
Africa and what your what what you think
and I'll be really interested in hearing
your thoughts on this as well Ralph in
terms of and anybody really how mobile
money begins to play into it because
that's another explosive phenomenon good
um that should touch everything that is
done especially when you're thinking
about how do you get your money back as
a film producer and you have people who
might be willing to pay the equivalent
of 50 cents sitting in Kenya you know
and you you blow that up over millions
of people and you begin to see some
things happen so that'd be really
interesting like to respond to um so
that's definitely something that's uh at
the Forefront for us is looking at these
other markets um you know we're trying
to basically apply that same platform
we've done about having um a systematic
marketing machine where we can
comprehensively uh put all the content
in one place and we've actually expanded
to Zimbabwe we had our first uh
Zimbabwean film uh come out a couple
weeks ago I guess apparently there's an
industry called zly wood that's slowly
growing um we've started zood yeah
exactly we're trying to take
over yeah Nollywood better watch out
we're coming um
and we've also started with Ganan movies
actually as well so Hollywood is way
behind watch special kinds of films
Inwood but yeah so we're definitely
trying to have a more Pana African
approach so Nollywood is you know what
Goddess start us goddess our name but it
is definitely a huge Market um in terms
of Distributing it um across Africa
we're doing that as well um I think
South Africa is another one of U place
we have a lot of our viewers um Kenya is
another place when nly would content is
very popular so we're trying to do more
marketing and also make sure that
Africans are also aware that we do have
this um content
available Colin any views on that uh
well I want to pick up on the mobile
money part which I think is a really
interesting one right especially if
you're talking about African but uh
developing country markets generally
where lots of people don't have credit
cards right that this is a huge problem
and all of a sudden when you have mobile
money it opens up all kinds of different
monetization opportunities so whether
the straightforward I'm going to pay 50
cents to watch this film on my mobile or
that we were talking about before this
kind of you know the dashing this
phenomenon of Dashing where you know
here for that's that's a tip jar like
what if I could send the actor in that
film my tip or the director or the
whatever what if you could do that in
that way say like I'm with you I'm your
side or it's a Kickstarter version or
you know it basically facilitates this
whole um channel of Commerce uh that is
otherwise much more difficult to do in
those kinds of
settings what happens but which country
in the world in the world is the leader
in Mobile money mobile Commerce and
mobile payments anyone want to Hazard a
guess or
pH anyone else United
States United States no any other
suggestions so the majority of the
respondents said Kenya they're quite
correct uh filler by the name of um well
forget his name for the moment but uh
there's company in Kenya called
safaricom which is like the vone of
Kenya about four years ago established
something called Mesa M
PESA it's now become the de facto
payment mechanism for 70% of kenyons you
can buy anything from a
Coca-Cola to paying for your kids school
fees on your phone and how you do it is
that the mechanism for doing it the
database that connects you into it and
it's primarily to the unbanked and the
uncredited is exactly the way that
credit cards work except your phone is
given a code and the code is connected
to your minutes and the minutes are then
settled between the bank and the Telco
and the net result is that you can use
your phone to pay for things this is now
spread through to Tanzania Uganda and
there've been a whole lot of copycats
all over Africa MTN money uh many
different kinds of mobile money and in
fact Visa internet interational based in
San Francisco 6 months ago bought a
company from South Africa called Fondo
for 110 million so that they could get
an accelerated vehicle to bring mobile
money not only to their in Visa
international but also to the United
States wow so paying exactly what you'd
said Mr Mallet where are you there you
are uh about paying for movies
bite-sized chunks of pieces of movies
this is something where if you can get
10 million people paying 15 cents or 20
cents or 50 cents because remember in
Africa money is hard to come by and the
vast majority of people live on less
than $5 a
day but certainly a very important area
let's any more questions from the floor
there we are go and take a mic and
there's another gentleman after that no
more women asking questions come on
ladies since Obama's Victory we need to
see more VIs
ility or
volubility go what's your name my name
is Arthur Arthur Musa and um I'm a
documentary filmmaker a new documentary
filmmaker and uh I'm working on two
projects right now um the first one is a
long-term four-year project where making
a film about how some African students
are becoming engineers at MIT so it's
taken them from you know when they
arrive until um when they graduate and
then the uh shorter term project was um
a documentary um I filmed about a group
of MIT students that got together and
did a robotics program in Nigeria in
Lagos this past summer um and so it was
10 days with them and you know how they
pulled it off um now the question I have
is um um is there a world of documentary
in in Africa you know are documentaries
being made um are they being
consumed what is out there um because
I'm an engineer I'm from Ghana actually
and um came to MIT trained as an
engineer but I've always had a passion
for storytelling and um you know that's
led me to become a filmmaker um and the
stories I'm interested in telling are
African stories uh hopefully that you
know can can Inspire Africans to do cool
things so
anyway I I have not been as familiar
with the documentary industry personally
in Africa I'm sure it exists you guys
aware I'll tell you that so I'm not I'm
going to give the same answer I don't
know but I'm totally with you I think I
mean My Hope of course um I love the I
love theatrical films and drama and so
forth but um the prospect of um people
uh telling those kinds of stories those
documentary stories as opposed to kind
of uh Western uh teams going in there
and telling you what you need to know
about country X or situation X to have
people in those settings telling those
stories to me seems just fundamentally
important and I feel like that's you
know I I don't know to the extent that
it's happening now I'm not aware of it
which suggests that if it is it's pretty
small um and it certainly is I mean you
have the funding problem you have the uh
Financial um sort of returns just I it
would be hard on the other hand you have
the skills and you have the tools
increasingly and the technology tools
and the platforms for people to be able
to do that you have Civil Society
increasingly thinking about um Nos and
so forth thinking about how do we tell
stories how do we use new technologies
to tell stories um whether it's using
platforms like usii or using phones or
or uh video so I I think we'll see it um
I don't think you're going to see it in
the same way uh taking the World by
storm you look at uh the US documentary
market right and that's a it's it's a
tough road to to uh ho here so it's
going to be even tougher there the
majority of the documentaries in Africa
have generally been directed towards
training training films to try and train
uh people in professional or or
artisanal
Pursuits we had a gentleman there uh yes
with his
hoodie yes my hoodie from the hood and I
have to FP the microphone
too um so what's your name my name is
Matea um I am U an artist I'm a
progressionist I'm an engineer and a
producer uh with sambalolo which is
based from Mali in West Africa um we
also founded a nonprofit organization
called Fen for uh um uh that focuses on
traditional African storytelling and PR
preserving traditional African
storytelling as well as uh opening new
markets for it so um I'm a messenger in
uh from uh the the way I experience West
Africa and the music in West
Africa is that
storytelling is a
job uh in West Africa much like uh
woodworking is or Metallurgy whatever
you want to call it so um I been my
question around this is I've heard a lot
about finance and mobile money and a lot
of Media stuff so my question is sitting
here at
MIT especially is around back what you
mentioned which is
gloal um gloal technology sounded like
autotune to me almost and one of the
things things that atin does for
traditional storytelling in Africa is it
removes the origin of it so in danger in
in accepting just technology any
technology in any way that we're
imposing with markets and money onto
Africa is great for traditional
storytelling where most of music comes
including hip-hop and and you know not
everything obviously but um that's our
mission so my question is do you see
accepting Technology based on markets or
how it Africa accepts that
technology so here here's the thing for
me there's two ways to look at the
continent that I think
we how do I put it I think a lot of
times when we look at Africa we see a
divide between the sort of traditional
vision of Africa the Grio the
Storyteller you know a guy with an amiro
or a won a lot of these beautiful
instruments and and how they practice
and represent African culture and
identity and then you have the other
side which is how young people which is
my primary interest in Africa are
actually living their daily lives and
the reality is the uptake and the the
degree to which technology is integrated
into people's lives is absolutely
massive and people have really taken it
and utiliz different Technologies in
ways that are in profoundly indigenously
uniquely African for example again with
the mobile phones who here knows what it
is to flash
somebody now I ain't talking about
taking your clothes off you see all
right all right so and I see these Gan
they know exactly what I'm talking about
what does it mean it means that I want
to say hi to you right M but I ain't got
that many minutes so I flash you which
is I ring you it rings once you see my
name or you see my phone number come up
I don't let it ring anymore if you call
me back I go say oh chal ra why you they
call me you know and and you be like y
man you just call me back like no I just
flash you I want you to know I'm
thinking about you you know what they
call that in England what the scotsman's
ring the Scotsman are
cheap that's fantastic that you pointed
that out because that is does that
Express what you are trying to
illustrate not not totally probably but
that that's just the an example of like
even a little thing like we're not
talking about Market or anything we're
just saying that the way we use
technology in arra is different from how
they use it in Atlanta and what you're
starting to see happen now and I've seen
it with so many of my peers is people
going home investing in projects in
Ghana people like Victor who are looking
at how can I do something there and I
think that part of what's going to
happen is those African communities will
determine the degree to which the the
the intersection of Market forces
traditional Force values and cultural
values and their own Creative
Expressions can be fused in a way that
works for them because what's happened
historically is we'll look and we'll say
you know oh you guys are you know this
is the way Africa could or should be I
mean I've had people tell me I remember
the the MIT station the MIT I'm going to
call people out the MIT radio station
wouldn't play my music when we were
first got started cuz they said it
wasn't African enough enough I mean we
were being listened to by millions of
kids in Ghana and they wouldn't play it
at MIT because somebody from Cambridge
knew what African music was right and it
took before a an East African DJ was
like yo man yo i y I keep listening to
your stuff how come you all don't have
that soulfish they were like we were
like one of the hot African bands coming
up out of Boston at the time Jonathan
can attest to this and then they were
like oh oh well oh we didn't know you
know and and so I I I would just say
that we have to be careful just as we
want to be careful in when we impose the
idea of how technology and markets would
play on the continent that we should be
careful how we how we understand how
those things do play on the continent
because a lot of us are looking and
we're like hey man like I get that the
Traditional Values are good but we also
see that those African artists those
African entrepreneurs they have to eat
and why shouldn't we be able to monetize
our vision of of the world using the
technologies that are available and
hopefully we're creating the next
Facebooks and Googles and twitters Out
of Africa as well well let me ask the
the gentleman that asked the question
this in Nigeria two guys Eric idahi and
danladi ver
veran saw Spotify being very successful
in Scandinavia and in Europe and decided
they would start their own West African
Spotify it's called spinlet spinlet
decom is that the kind of engineering
thinking that you are referring to where
you're saying what is going on is it
that the youth love technology love
digital engineering love stuff that will
give them some kind of global something
with an African voice um so I can't
actually answer the Spotify question
because I don't think Spotify uh
provides any support for the artist so
that's not what I want for Africa um but
uh I think I I didn't make my myself
clear I support the gloal thing I think
that there's real Innovation and and
there's going to be a boom in growth
creative growth there but the gloal
vocal is what I was referring to which
is hey I'm going to sing in this
language and translate it for me in like
these 17 other languages um is just the
same thing that autotune did which is
remove you know remove who is the origin
of the message so musicians and artists
we're Messengers right um and that that
should be important was so this this is
tradition and this is your job in in
Africa right the G the jelly whatever
the g whatever you call it um
so in some way it is my job to even ask
this question but uh uh question in my
mind Nollywood is has done is is uh is
done for the video and movies what Ivory
Coast has done for the music production
in West Africa which is as fast as
possible let's see how we can monetize
this technology so I'm saying yes we
should I'm not saying no we shouldn't
but I'm saying we need to be careful how
and not just accept models that're
coming just like autotune for example
which has done you know I don't know I
switch off the radio when I hear autot
so so I hope you don't use that you I I
respect your heart and everything for
sure no I I I do understand what you're
saying and I hate autotune I figure why
not just learn to sing and pitch or Sing
Off Pitch I mean like but do it I and
and I think the technology the
technology you're talking about you're
literally saying he's raising a very
powerful point which is that if you take
a technology that can take your vocal
Essence and wrap it into another
language are you losing something in the
literally in the translation and I think
it's a very we do have yes there there
there's hundreds of languages there as
well as in India um and you
know it it shouldn't be we shouldn't try
to be monetizing on the on the culture
through through you know it just sounds
wrong to me uh autotune removes that it
removes that connection but also it's
you know it is technology that's
available that will bring you money at
this point there is you know industry
that will you know you'll get more money
to make that song If you do put autotune
on it so you're going to put it anyway
that you know what I mean because you
can use anything anything that would get
you more popularity on Spotify or
whatever it is so you literally change
the way you transmit messages I think
autotune is a fad frankly I don't think
you hear it as much now as you did three
years ago and I think in two years it'll
nobody would even dare put it on cuz
it'll sound corny but the
incontrovertible fact is that young
people in Africa today are consumed and
completely obsessed by wanting new
technology new digitalia this is what
they want let's get a lady to ask a
question come on
girls don't be so mute come on we're in
Boston surely you have a question for
the Holy Trinity here no this G
gentlemen
here what are we going to do come on
girls I'm sorry I'm not a lady tell us
your name
and it's okay you could be if you wanted
to be oh this
way um my name is federo federo I'm
Italian Spanish and for that reason I
want to excuse my jet leg English also
because I've just landed in Boston and
I'm not so active like you r
um I want to thank you all really for
this panel because I find it fascinating
also because I've been working in this
field since I was a teenager I happened
to grow up in a very small town in
southern Spain where we a group of uh
crazy people at the moment we founded an
African Film Festival now called tarfa
Cordoba African Film Festival then I
studied journalism I don't want to tell
the story of my life but just to
um tell you how I got to Kenya and um
and work in this similar field and um I
I had the chance of work as a cultural
cooperation officer for the Spanish
agency of international cooperation in
this last two years in Nairobi Kenya and
that I worked with a group of upcoming
Young filmmakers from the slums uh
mainly K kibera and matare and we
started up a small Film Festival with
them they're called the Isam Film
Festival which for me it's a bit of a
very small scale example of this big
discussion about how media new
technologies and New Media are
empowering uh communities as well in
Africa um and my question is for um
Colin actually because I find when I um
worked in Kenya I found also fascinating
how young um uh Kenyans are using
mobile technologies not only to consume
uh cultural products but also to produce
their own cultural products and that was
the idea fund for me to fund the slam
film festival and so uh I happened to
discover uh this fascinating work of
what a Scottish well South African uh
scholar called prosumption the
production plus consumption Factor so I
wonder if you also look at it in your uh
Civic uh New Media uh usage to
understand what are the needs of local
communities I mean so I think this
addresses to you also addressed the
previous question right about sort of
imposing technology and I guess my view
is that technology as we've heard is
coming uh people want technology and so
that the best thing that we can do is
help them to navigate what it is to use
technology effectively right so thinking
about their um kind of information and
media literacy on the consumption side
but uh as importantly on the production
side and we in the US I would say are
much more oriented towards consumption
for a whole variety of reasons cultural
in some cases but really Business Heavy
reasons right where even the way that
you access your internet often the
upload speeds are different from the
download seeds we want to be you know
we're told to buy stuff and to consume
stuff and to me the really exciting
thing about the the cost of these
Technologies and uh the power uh and the
Simplicity is that all of a sudden you
can have a tremendous number of new
creators in the space um and and what
our so we you know one of the big uh
research efforts are on the Bergman
center youth and media uh project and
the youth media lab is what we see is
that the way that kids learn things this
will not come as a surprise to anyone in
the room is by doing right and the way
that they learn about um about sort of
media New Media literacies and learning
about in Henry in the back of the room
who can talk this much more effectively
than I can but one of the big ways that
they learn about how to consume things
is by producing and they learn about uh
intellectual property and their views on
it when they have their own thing to
share or not share and to decide how to
treat it um so I I guess for me I see
this just with these kinds of um uh
inexpensive phones the capacity to put
stuff on YouTube or whatever the uh
local equivalent is and to make their
own uh make their own works and it gets
to the documentary gets anything else
it's just an amazing opportunity for
modern storytelling and to continue
in that oral tradition and to make it
your your job um so I I think it's do
you think it reduces the cultural
authenticity or increases it oh it
absolutely increases it it gives you it
gives you tools potentially to be
yourself and be more than you could
otherwise be right because you get to I
I get to take your picture I get to mash
it up I get to add dereck's fabulous
music to it I get to do this and that I
can make money off it too but I can
express myself um and so I think that's
where but the key there is that people
have the capacity to access and
understand how to use those tools if I
may just attach to that conversation so
that that does sound like the tools that
we're bringing there should be both
capable of production and consumption
right so it should be a little more than
a screen right so uh wouldn't it be them
better to bring in if we could God knows
the best bring in the best to bring in
the iPhone not the my iPhone my phone
whatever that was the cheapest thing
right because the one that that would be
also capable of production not just
consumption doesn't doesn't that mean
yes perhaps we need a little a little
bit little more expensive technology and
and we should be thinking about invest
investing in these terms or not I I put
it like this everyone anyone who can
afford an iPhone in Africa right now
already has one right like it's not like
you can't have an iPhone I mean some
people have an iPhone and don't even
they they have it just to show up they
exactly they they got all the
blackberries in the Sun got all the
Nokia devices that we don't even buy out
here because Nokia has no Market
penetration I'm saying that it's not
that those Technologies are not
available but for the person who is like
hey I want a smartphone and I don't have
$400 um what about them and so what
you're seeing is it's not a matter of an
either or it's an and but and and the
iPhone I mean the my phone if it doesn't
have a camera now it's going to have a
camera I mean it's got one so then there
you go video there you go it's got It's
democratized production values in a $30
device bam bam
done let's get ladies give us what we
only got time for two more questions so
ah here we go all right I could take it
anymore um what's your name my name is
elanar I might be putting my foot in my
mouth because I missed the first half
hour so I hope you guys didn't already
talk about this but I was curious you
were talking about the lady who went
around the merchant Banker who went
around was trying to get fun funding for
this movie from these corporations we
completely covered that already I know
yeah that that I got but I'm curious
like a lot of the funding we've talked
about other than that example is coming
from like foundations or from actually
distribution in the country in the brief
period where you can have a theatrical
release or licensing deals from your
site what about corporations being
involved in funding movies and why is it
that they're not more involved I mean
here we have corporations doing product
placement uh sponsoring cultural events
like concerts so is there resistance in
Africa to that that type of involvement
and why there is one Afric there's one
uh large American corporation Pepsi
who've been told by Indra Nui who is the
global head of Pepsi saying Emerging
Markets are really important do
something in Africa that can stimulate
what we've been trying to do in the
United States as they did a couple of
weeks ago in New York City with Nicki
Minaj now it doesn't mean you got to
find the Nicki minage of Lagos but they
will be putting money where their mouth
is what you suest gesting is a fantastic
idea and can I jump in on goes so yeah I
mean we have I apologize for not having
addressed this so far so the origin of
this film industry right is that the
marketers which is to say people who
sell sold then video cassettes and now
DVDs in the market um made a film to
sell video cassettes right so this is
and those are the folks they're Cally
known as the marketers but they're kind
of the executive producers and they fund
almost all these films these films are
typically funded self-funded funded by
Family funded by marketers who also
control the distribution so um some
people are kind to the marketers some
people are really not kind to the
marketers it's a it's a really uh it's a
rough system um which um reinforces the
limited amount of money reinforces uh
most people would argue low production
values and quick turnaround um and has a
effectively uh control over distribution
and also allegations are that at least
some of these marketers are actually
also Pirates so that you have the same
people who are ostensibly your executive
producer selling out the back so it's
not the kind of piracy that we see in
the west right this is a different kind
of
piracy are you sure it well it's but
here in the west it's like an individual
it's like me you know downloading
something and here you have like
someone's given her 100,000 copies of a
vcd and then they're given me 100,000
copies and I'm walking out the back of
the shop right so um it's a real problem
it's real it's it really limits the um
and it's and it's not great for the
marketers either right for the legit
ones the illegitimate ones have to deal
with um paying people off extensively
and all sorts of risks and the
legitimate ones are dealing with the
Pirates too so it's a it's a rough
system there have been a number of
different attempts to deal with this
distribution funding thing another I
mean another element of the problem is
that there's there's not a lot of
transparency in the um in the film
industry so nobody knows how many copies
are sold nobody knows how many copies
are viewed there's no way to track it
there's no box office revenue so you
can't like the way we we do here there's
no they don't like to show their books
so if you're a company who's going to
invest in their film they're like no no
no this is Art you know I'm not showing
you my book yeah um so there are a whole
host of those um chall and then you have
the legal issues right there's no um
there's no contract there's no no no one
knows who owns the IP there's no
signature you know just it's a very kind
of opaque system which the legal system
is slow and arguably dysfunctional so
there's a real problem there and this is
actually one of the things that um I did
not start off saying we need to deal
with this but this is clearly um at the
root of so much of the challenge to the
industry right now is figuring out how
to finance films so that you can make
the full range of films from crappy two
week you know action or whatever to
really thoughtful great literature
highbrow amazing stuff or you know
whatever filmmakers want to make and
whatever consumers want to consume there
should be that possibility but right now
there absolutely isn't that possibility
and so I think one of the things that
we're trying to work through is how do
you change that Dynamic and so as Ralph
alluded you have good luck Jonathan this
next this $200 million fund hasn't done
it I think there are questions whether
you can get other kinds of companies to
to address that but you're going to it's
going to require more transparency it's
going to require more opportunities for
Revenue in the country so oroko um uh
and other you know sort of streams like
that matter but they're not sufficient
to get the kind of returns you need so
one of the things that most is to say
that this is the this is a really
important challenge well I think um just
add what you're were saying with the
funding issue feel free to tell me I'm
wrong I complet spot on um I think is
the nature of the industry being so
fragmented like in the US you have the
big production houses Hollywood is
basically five big production houses as
there it's like 400 different producers
I think it's a lot harder to be able to
invest in a big project I think the way
it works in US is that you have a big
production house the winners basically
fund the losers and so you can put your
money behind um big films you basically
take make your bets but I think in a
market like that where it's just so
fragmented there's so little budgets I
think it's very hard to be able to
really fund a big project maybe there
need to be changes in terms of
consolidating the production houses
maybe that can be something mov the
right direction of funding yeah I mean I
think there's we we would I would
actually personally love to get into a
deeper conversation on the business
models behind all this stuff because
part of the reason you see these big
movies made in the United States frankly
is because they sell popcorn um and
that's and if you actually look at how
this stuff works the movies that sell
popcorn are the ones that get made
specifically movies that sell popcorn to
teenage boys um movies that are made for
girls are so that the teenage boys will
take a girl and buy her popcorn that is
the underpinning of the American
Hollywood film industry popcorn is not
popular in Nigeria not exactly exactly
which is why I'm like Fufu style if we
had the way to sell a Fufu we're going
to make more movies where is that
documentary so two quick points one
actually interestingly from what Colin
said about about the the the the actual
physical product is where a lot of the
growth in in Hollywood was stimulated
and and Jonathan I know was smiling when
we're saying like the piracy is
different but the there's something also
interesting that we should be aware of
that's happening in the American
industry I talked to a guy uh I used to
work with called Les bider for 25 years
he ran Warner Chapel which was at the
time the largest music publishing
company in the world and a point that he
made is that that a lot of people don't
think about is that one of the big
issues facing the record indust right
now is that the rise of digital it's not
just that people can steal your music
it's that all the major record labels in
the 80s and 90s bought distribution
companies which means that if you sold a
million records like they were going to
you know have to have a million physical
records or physical tapes or physical
CDs to sell you and they may cost them 5
cents to make those CDs but they're
going to charge the artist a dollar and
so that's a million dollars in Revenue
now you're selling digital content you
made One MP3 file or maybe you made five
of different types of quality how many
times do you sell that product right so
literally in the American scene we're
dealing with the same issue of once you
go digital you remove the opportunity
for the guy who makes the widget to sell
the widget to second thing to your point
of like where do corporations come in
there was an interesting project that
happened a few years out go out of South
Africa where Guinness funded an action
movie and we're talking High budget
multi-million dollar high production
value action film around the guy who all
of us who drink Guinness in Africa would
see on the Billboards he's a handsome
brother with bald head look just like me
and he be there like Guinness the power
right and Guinness the power became an
action hero so it'll be intriguing to
see if you have more of that kind of
thing happen yeah and well just to pile
on that and it should be noted right
that product placement like Blackberry
girls or phone swap these are other
films that product placement um is a
pretty you know advertising $600 million
in Nigeria something like that big
opportunity and ironically right this is
where piracy Works in their favor the
more movies that get out there like hey
that's great right so that so that kind
of is one of those that pushes the other
direction and remember Guinness is the
biggest alcohol brand in Nigeria the
biggest and you drink it to slake your
thirst and also because it gives you
extra masculinity and on that note of
extra masculinity ladies we'd like to
end it with some music because we feel
that getting a good vibe as we go out
with these two great performers let's
hear some Fufu
style so in in honor of the Fufu I
actually want to because we've spoken so
much about Nollywood which I think is an
African treasure and I think that its
best days are are still to come and we
should give props to Nigeria for really
pioneering a a phenomenon a global
phenomenon I want to do a Nigerian song
uh it's actually an EO song and it's
very very simple and a Nigerian
filmmaker taught it to me years and
years and years ago I never F got it and
because my I can't speak Evo I roughly
translate it means something along the
lines of peace be still anybody here
speak Evo okay good it means all the
goodness and the Poetry of the world and
it means Derek is dope and you can take
that to the bank um but the song says
de
[Music]
ladies and Gentlemen please give a warm
Round of Applause
Colin
fi
Derek thank you so much